so the 4th of July um okay first of all
I'm yelling at my youngest daughter so
if you see I'm yelling at her I'm the
mama you know this a bear I'm I'm
roaring right now so I'm yelling and
then I come in there and I say something
to you and I got an attitude me if I was
there I'm like girl bye you talk at me
you don't talk to me oh you're too
sensitive no I'm not yes you are I don't
like that like I'm not going to be on no
no you don't know how to you don't take
what people say to you and you don't be
like okay well I did this I'm sorry you
don't know how to apologize you be like
okay well get over it like oh
well so this is what I call the ghetto
mom the ghetto mom the abusive mom um
she's constantly not apologizing for
anything she's constantly blaming her
daughter and she doesn't act like a
mother that actually loves her daughter